so what happened at unite the right to a
massive police presence escorted a
handful of white supremacists to the
electro station in Virginia cameras were
everywhere
one guy was arrested for spitting on a
Virginia State Police officer after a
short ride to deceive a few Nazis
actually showed their faces in public a
few hundred anti-fascists hid there's
thousands of counter protesters from
diverse backgrounds rallied chanted and
marched in the streets cameras were
everywhere some guy burned a Nazi /
Confederate flag hybrid and this guy
dressed up as Indiana Jones because
Nazis as for the right-wing protests I
have no idea what they said because they
were completely drowned out by loud boos
and game of thrones' as the rain fell on
Lafayette Square the crowds began to
disperse most counter protesters never
even saw anyone from the far-right at
the rally I saw a few of them on their
way out it was like a handful
they have a basic right to protest we
have a right to protest so we show up
with more numbers they just can't put on
a showing like they think they do I
think that they're far outnumbered by
the American people their movements is
basically just incredibly weak and
should stop stopping Nazis
[Music]